the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you will have on your scale
[Music]
how are you guys doing the American
elections are just around the corner and
many people in the Muslim Community are
thinking what should we do there a
difference of opinions that exists in
the Muslim Community uh that I've been
seeing and been privy to on social media
some people saying that well we should
vote for Harris and all the Democrats
because
they are the lesser of two evils and
others saying well actually Donald Trump
he represents much more of our values
than Harris the truth of the matter is
that both of those individuals are
vehement supporters of the state of
Israel and there is a long track record
of both of those candidates not just
rhetorically supporting the state of
Israel but materially doing so as well
take a look at this video of for example
the latest campaign of Donald Trump one
of the people spokespersons there
speaking and let's come back and respond
in kind and the Palestinians are taught
to kill us at 2 years old they won't let
a Palestinian in Jordan they won't let a
Palestinian in Egypt and Harris wants to
bring them to
you they may have good people I'm sorry
I don't take a risk with people that are
taught to kill Americans at two I'm on
the side of
Israel you're on the side of Israel
Donald Trump's on the side of Israel and
they're on the side of the
terrorists so there's no doubt about it
that um these candidates and parties
have unequivocal and unconditional
support for the state of Israel and for
the Muslim people what it should be the
case very clear clear for me anyway is
that we should let them work for it at
the end of the day and I more than that
I would say I think it's quite
abominable and
condemnable that we talk about boycotts
and not going to Starbucks and not going
to McDonald's and these kinds of places
which is very good however on the one
hand you talk about boycotts because you
don't want to support a multinational
company which directly or indirectly
supports the state of Israel in fact
many of those companies on the boycott
list are are there there because the
CEOs for example and some of the longer
boycott lists have said something
positive about the state of Israel so
you say that on the one hand on the
other hand you talk about Kamala Harris
being the lesser of two evils that
doesn't sorry to say make any sense
because if in principle it's wrong to
lend support or give legitimacy to a
body or an
organization which lends support in turn
to the entity the Zionist entity then by
extension giving a political mandate
okay giving legitimacy through political
mandate by giving your a vote should be
even more uh condemnable which it is in
fact there's nothing more that you can
give to someone uh than than your vote
really it's even worse than giving them
your money so I think this should be
very clear now some people have
suggested that okay well why don't we
vote for uh Jill Stein for example or a
third party candidate now something like
that could work but then it has to have
the community support and I I think I
mean um the American Muslim Community
have to come together and work that out
um like we did here in the UK I mean if
you look at our recent elections we we
got independence in in the um you know
many Independence Muslim Independence uh
at an unprecedented scale because there
was many initiatives like the Muslim
vote initiative which unified and
centralized our efforts and what I'm
saying to you is that maybe we could do
the same thing um when I went to Norway
the guys in Islam net who you saw the
advert of in the beginning of this video
have an even more interesting thing
which is that they created this website
in Norwegian which ranks all of the
political parties uh compared to all the
things that Muslims care about of course
Gaza and Palestine was at the top
and those parties were so affected by
that move that they started to get in
contact with them to try and boost their
ratings on that particular website the
key message here is actually there's
more than one number one is I think it's
morally objectionable okay to vote for
any body or any political entity or
person who in turn lends their support
to the state of Israel considering
45,000 at least people have been
brutally murdered in Gaza we how could
you how can you vote for someone who
supports that in any way who doesn't
want to see an end to that in any way
who's not very clear-cut in an end to
that in any way why would you want th
that blood in your hands frankly that's
the truth of the matter you have some
responsibility because you're giving
these people a political mandate so I I
see it as politically morally
objectionable the second thing is I
think that America being a huge country
I mean people in the west or I should
say people in Europe don't realize that
America is almost comparable to all of
Western Europe maybe with even part of
you know um Central Europe you could say
it's a huge country with 50 states 330
million people uh the Muslim Community
is not as big by ratio as it is for
example the United Kingdom and or in any
other the cities as it is in the United
Kingdom or many of the European
countries like France Etc so it's even
more difficult because of geographic
landscape Etc to do this to to
centralize however if you have online
initiatives and you bring leaders
Community leaders and influentials
together then I think the job can still
be
done and some would say what you what
are you talking about why are you even
giving your opinion on this matter when
you're all the way here in the United
Kingdom I sorry to say but you know
United Kingdom probably for me to get to
New York is a similar distance to get
from one place in America to another uh
the world has become a you know Village
uh globalization has made us see what's
going on with Donald Trump's made us see
what's going with Kam Kamala H cabal
Harris what we call this individual but
so it doesn't really matter to be honest
with you I mean the Bible Belt versus
South um America as you know the culture
in South America versus Northeast
there's a world of difference between
that you could say you know people in
Europe yeah places in Europe are closer
in culture than parts of the Northeast
comp comparative to Northeast and South
so this thing about okay why is this
person with this citizenship commenting
on this issue and this I mean why are we
talking about Palestine and Middle East
anyway all the way here in the west this
is a nonse secator and it's a fallacious
type of argument but this is just me
lending uh you know giving some
arguments or giving my opinion and
that's that's all I've got to
say Hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a mid a dawa Center
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more